someone's going out saying hey you're
you're a difficult person who only cares
about the money and uh that you're a
and you had the opportunity to
clear it in because with verifiably
untrue which now no one is arguing
what you doing
how else do would people switch from it
was about a 50 million dollar salary to
oh recording a phone call just James
do we allow when James O'Keefe does it
is it only when corruption is on the
side of the left and here's the issue is
I'll tell you who this hurts the
dishonesty I'm not just saying daily
wire this is really this is about the
entire movement as a whole
there are a lot of practices that go on
and it hurts the sponsors hurts the
creators hurts the viewers hurts the
investors and by investors with us you
know it's entirely mug Club it's people
who pay to subscribe we don't make a
dime off of YouTube we haven't for many
years and it hurts what I if if you
believe what we say we believe the
movement in the country as a whole so
that right there right is fundamentally
designed and the gas lining still keeps
taking place Candice Owens on this show
said
um hey we all follow the same guidelines
right we all follow that Crowder does
too that's verifiably false